[Música]
[Aplausos]
buenas noches con todos igual que
introducción muchas gracias
la verdad estoy bastante emocionada de
estar aquí
si el día de hoy me preguntan
qué es el éxito para mí
el éxito para mí es estar aquí no por el
reconocimiento sino por haber logrado
salir de mi casa sin que mis hijas
lloren
el día de hoy ha sido un día bastante
largo una preparación
bastante compleja no estoy acostumbrada
a hablar en público pero lo he hecho
porque
he querido llegar a esa mujer
que seguramente tiene esa pasión por
conectarse
con este proyecto que quiera desarrollar
y espero llegar con un mensaje a no una
sino a varias mujeres
hace 12 años
yo empecé a trabajar en un medio de
comunicación
y arranque como un puesto bastante
interesante en el área comercial
yo estaba aprendiendo y aplicando muchos
de mis conocimientos en ese momento
estaba estudiando en mi ingeniería en
administración de empresas y pues pasé
por algunas experiencias laborales y
justamente podía notar cuando compartía
este esta experiencia con mi familia
notaba en la cara de mis padres de mis
amigos de mis colegas trabajar en este
medio de comunicación para ellos era un
orgullo era una admiración inclusive
cuando visitaba a algunos clientes y me
tocaba esperar en recepción hasta que me
atiendan me preguntaban en de qué medio
es y una vez que lo decía algo mágico
pasaba y me hacían me hacían asistir a
la sala de reunión para finalmente poder
presentar mi mis propuestas comerciales
poco a poco este reconocimiento de estar
en un medio de comunicación bastante
importante el más importante del país se
fue convirtiendo y se podría decir como
en mí en mi carta de presentación
en ese momento creí que había alcanzado
se podría decir que gran parte de mi
carrera profesional
cuatro años después conozco al que ahora
es mi esposo él la saca de ohio de eeuu
tenemos tres niños
y pues antes de casarnos había un
acuerdo se podría decir que no podíamos
salir del país que nos conocimos acá y
le dijo ok vamos a hacer una familia acá
vamos a hacer una carrera acá pero no es
una opción salir de ecuador
a veces uno planifica mucho pero
realmente estas cosas no funcionan así
un año después me dice mi esposo tengo
una propuesta laboral combinada con la
academia creo que es una gran
oportunidad y me parece que es hora de
que nos vayamos de acá
si estás equivocado no vamos a salir nos
vamos a quedar aquí
esta es mi cultura mis amigos mi familia
no voy a salir de guayaquil
yo creo que esta fue una de las
experiencias
más relevantes de mi vida como mujeres
conectarme con mi sería decir vamos a
acceder vamos a romper ese
esos límites que mi personalidad me está
dando que mi carácter me está imponiendo
y vamos a acceder este es un matrimonio
es una relación creo que tiene que
funcionar de esta forma
cuando nos mudamos a columbus a columbus
ohio para mí fue un mundo nuevo
estaba totalmente perdida totalmente
perdida no conocí a nadie más que mi
familia política y mi esposo y decía qué
voy a hacer aquí cometió un error no sé
qué estoy haciendo acá
decidí involucrarme en la universidad mi
esposo iba todos los días a las charlas
talleres conferencias todo lo que pueda
ver todas las actividades me sabía todas
las áreas de los campus sabía dónde
estaban los parqueaderos era una de las
universidades más grandes de eeuu una de
las más importantes y ya me sabía
absolutamente todas las actividades que
estaban ocurriendo allá
logro trabajar allí
y me conecté con muchas personas comencé
a [ __ ] confianza y dije creo que puedo
hacer una vida acá
empecé a estudiar mi maestría en
administración de empresas y a la par se
me da la oportunidad de trabajar en una
de las empresas automovilísticas más
grandes de los eeuu
empiezo a trabajar en un bmw bmw y
después de eso fue mi graduación cuando
estaba en la maestría de capiro
university junto con mi familia
y logró ingresar a esta empresa
y en cuatro años de haber estado en esta
compañía logró crear tres promociones
para mí esto era el cúspide de mi
carrera profesional yo dije bueno acá
voy a hacer carrera voy a continuar
probablemente puede hacer
la supervisora de mi departamento fue
todo un reto fue todo un reto porque yo
recibía información financiera de méxico
tenía que traducirla dar mi propio punto
de vista financiero para poder
presentarlos a los directivos en
alemania
una vez que estuve conversando con mi
esposo sobre ésta
y se podría decir decisión de seguir
haciendo carrera dentro de eeuu quedó
embarazada de mi primera hija y nace ahí
por primera vez mi conexión con el lado
maternal
y pienso creo que es una buena
oportunidad para regresar el ecuador
y hacer familia
que mis que mi hija o mi hijo no sabía
era un embarazo sorpresa se pueda
conectar con su familia extendida
aparte de eso dije con toda esta
preparación que logré en el exterior
seguramente hay alguien que me quiera
contratar seguramente hay alguien que me
quiera dar un puesto para poder aplicar
todo lo que yo aprendí
regreso nuevamente el mismo medio de
comunicación esta vez como supervisora
de operaciones comerciales del cual yo
me tengo que encargar de la distribución
de la señal a nivel latinoamericano
jamás había tenido a mi cargo
un equipo
pero fue allí cuando tuve un wake up con
una llamada que dije este puesto de
supervisora
me va a ayudar a mí a conectarme con mi
equipo quiero romper esas pesas
paradigmas del jefe y los empleados
entonces comienzo a conectarme con mi
equipo
comienzo a compartir experiencias
compartir todo lo que sabía comienzo a
empujarlos a que vengan conmigo a
capacitaciones y después de un año haber
trabajado con ellos creó una conexión
una conexión muy importante y el cual se
vio resultados en las ventas y en las
operaciones que se iban dando en el día
a día
después de un año de haber estado allí
como embarazada por segunda vez
trato de para no detener las operaciones
internas de trabajar desde casa con mi
segunda hija regresó a la oficina
después de los tres meses y me dicen
sabes que lisette y muchas gracias pero
ya no necesitamos tus servicios
estaba bastante decepcionada y por un
momento estaba enojada porque dije bueno
este es el rol de convertirme en madre
por segunda vez hizo que perdiera a uno
de los trabajos más importantes de mi
vida
pero después dije no esta es una
oportunidad es una oportunidad para
crear una conexión que mi hija es una
oportunidad para para desarrollar un
proyecto es un proyecto en el cual yo
pueda hacer mi propia jefa yo pueda
decidir en qué tiempo le dedico a poder
seguir creciendo profesionalmente pero
dándole la prioridad a lo maternal a mi
maternidad
creo este emprendimiento que es un
portabebés perdón
y este portabebés después de cinco meses
en el mercado crece significativamente
porque crece crece porque comienza a
crecer una comunidad también parte del
valor agregado de este producto de
entregarlo en persona a cada una de las
mamás que se convertían en mamás y que
no tengan que salir de sus casas
entonces yo iba junto con mis otras dos
socias a entregar el producto y les
explicaba cómo utilizarlo pero
identificamos que realmente lo que las
mujeres querían era conectarse con otras
mujeres querían compartir esa
experiencia de la lactancia del proceso
cambio del cuerpo y de otra vez tratar
de reconectarse consigo mismas
busque varios lugares para seguir
desarrollando mi proyecto y hoy en día
hay muchos coworking fui a uno de ellos
y la verdad no me sentí mucho muy muy
cómodas para los que no saben que es un
coworking es un lugar que brinda
espacios de trabajo sin tener se podría
decir un
un pago fijo en relación el agua luz la
recepcionista y es una facilidad que se
le brinda a los emprendedores para no
tener este este pago a largo plazo
fui a otro más probé algunos no me
gustaron no sentí que no daban la
bienvenida a la mujer era como muy
corporativo no tengo nada en contra de
que los chicos estén allí pero estaba
muy enfocado en tener un ambiente muy
serio entonces converso con mi esposo y
le digo yo creo que tiene que ver
seguramente otras mujeres que se sientan
igual que yo y cuando te dicen no
compartas tu proyecto o tu idea con
nadie eso no es verdad yo sugiero
compartan lo compartan lo compartan la
idea comenten lo con otras personas con
amigos con extraños
bueno fundamos
como address coworking
el 24 de enero de este año
con madres es el primer coworking
enfocado en mujeres y madres
emprendedoras en el que tenemos un área
de cuidado de niños y las mujeres como
yo que somos madres podemos llevar a
nuestros hijos aparte de eso tenemos una
comunidad bastante fortalecida está
compuesta de mujeres sumamente
es sumamente
empoderadas y sé que está muy trillado
este término pero realmente son mujeres
empoderadas son mujeres en las cuales
ellas van y solas se presentan sólo
presentan su proyecto y se han conectado
y han logrado muchas alianzas gracias a
esta plataforma además de esto tenemos
una tienda en las que ellas pueden poner
en exhibición sus productos y además de
eso también tenemos con padres ahora hay
tres hombres el día de hoy ella hay tres
hombres también en nuestras
instalaciones utilizando nuestras
oficinas
qué quiero decir con esto quiero decir
que no se puede lograr este tipo de
proyectos hola
si no fuera por el empuje de mi esposo
la motivación que el día a día me dice
vamos tú puedes es cansado pero si se
puede se puede lograr
se puede lograr siempre que tú levanten
la mano y digas necesito ayuda es
importante conectarse es importante
crear tu tribu es importante crear una
comunidad una comunidad compuesta de
mujeres y de hombres también que
realmente quieren apoyar de una forma
desinteresada
hoy en día tenemos una comunidad como
les comenté bastante fortalecida hay
muchas mujeres las cuales mujeres que no
tienen hijos y que tienen hijos y han
desarrollado sus proyectos de una manera
bastante significativa bastante
relevante y con un gran aporte a nuestra
sociedad a nuestra economía porque estas
personas que tienen sus negocios
contratan a una o dos personas que están
fomentando el empleo
este es un pequeño vídeo
es un pequeño vídeo en como una
demostración de la celebración que
tuvimos en el día del international
coworking day cuando celebramos el día
internacional de coworking pueden ver
varias de las mujeres que están
participando en este evento muchas de
ellas y asocias a través de una oficina
a través de una membresía o inclusive a
través de las actividades
ese día celebramos también nuestro caso
de responsabilidad social todas
aportamos de una u otra forma hicimos
equipo y desarrollamos un plan de
negocios en el que estaba compuesto por
un plan de ventas un plan de imagen de
producción para dos personas de escasos
recursos
nos unimos todas nos unimos y nos
empoderamos de este negocio que no era
el nuestro para poder ayudar a estas
personas entonces el día de hoy les
puedo decir
qué es el éxito para mí el éxito para mí
es poder estar acá con ustedes compartir
y poder llegar a esa mujer que quiere
hacer una combinación que quiere hacer
que quiere conciliar su vida laboral con
su vida familiar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]